entire lifespan as a company we've
always highlighted our team members
a lot of amazing stories with within our
company we love highlighting people
so that was the first part and then
today we're shooting our tv commercial
which is highlighting a very fun aspect
of our company and all of our team
members so how does tao
tell the story of the life behind
station casinos and its people
while staying relevant in our ever
evolving technological world today
qn devonte house
[Applause]
nothing says celebration like a dance
party and that's exactly what tal
envisioned
when they brought tick tocker devonte
house on board a big dance celebration
from the heart of the casino
its people he created a dance for us and
the team members love
at first they're very nervous they don't
know what to expect but then after five
minutes of teaching them
they're all having a good time and
loving it and i love catching people
having a good time and i think we all
love that as a company
it was crazy because like everybody's
everybody walked up at first and they
were like so like you know
nothing you know it's early in the
morning but then we start
get to move it and i'm seeing smiles
everyone's having fun like
i feel like everyone everyone
their energy got brought up from this
and i feel like
the whole atmosphere is going to be
different after this
a very different atmosphere for sure
because that atmosphere would be nothing
without the palace station team members
and its guests
[Music]
most importantly thank you thank you for
staying with us
thank you for being with us
being loyal thank you for making us as
great as we are thank you for
making us the property that we've been
over the last 45 years
tomorrow